- [Instructor] When we
left off in the last video,
things were not going particularly well
for the English settlers at Jamestown.
They had managed to
survive a couple of years
by the skin of their teeth,
but by 1610, they had endured
such incredible starvation
that they were actually leaving.
And as they were just
leaving the Chesapeake Bay,
they met a ship with
English reinforcements,
who ordered them back to Jamestown,
and came bearing orders from England
about a new strategy in Jamestown.
And these new orders were
carried by a new commander,
here this was Lord De La Warr.
Spelled a little bit different,
but the state of Delaware today
is named after this gentleman.
And Lord De La Warr said,
"Well, it's been great
"that you've all been trying to get along
"with these Powhatans, but
let's get rid of them."
So he switched the English from their
small amount of conflict
with the Native Americans
over stealing food,
to a pretty much all-out war of extinction
against the Powhatans.
And De La Warr was a veteran
of the Irish campaigns
to subdue that colony.
So he brings his
tactics of complete
brutality and submission
of the native population to the New World.
He raids Native American villages.
He burns their crops,
and generally promotes an idea
that they'll be no such thing
as peaceful co-existence
between English settlers
and Native Americans.
That the only thing for
Native Americans to do
is go away or die.
And these conflicts between
the English colonists
and the Native Americans living
in this Virginia tidewater
are called the Anglo-Powhatan Wars.
The first Anglo-Powhatan war ended in 1614
with a brief period of peace,
when this fellow here, John Rolfe
married Pocahontas.
As kind of a
peace offering.
But, by the time
that the second Anglo-Powhatan
war was over in 1625,
pretty much the entire Powhatan tribe
had either been killed,
or driven from the area,
and therefore this
English war of extinction
against Native Americans had succeeded.
Now John Rolfe made another contribution
to the colony at Jamestown,
beyond his marriage with Pocahontas,
he also discovered that tobacco
was a perfect crop
for the kind of marshy Virginia soil.
And tobacco was a commodity
that was getting hotter
and hotter in Europe,
and so they discovered
that they could grow
pretty much as much tobacco
as they possibly could,
and markets in Europe would just
buy it and buy it and buy it.
And so, although the
colonists at Jamestown
didn't find the gold that
they were hoping for,
they found a very
different way to get rich,
and that was through cultivating tobacco.
And this is going to have
enormous consequences
for the development of
Virginia as a colony,
both in terms of its geographic
development, and also the
development of its labor force.
As tobacco is an incredibly
labor-intensive crop,
these English planters in Virginia
will quickly look for ways to staff
a labor force in the New World.
And one way that they
will do this is through
the importation of African slaves.
The very first slave ship
arrived in Jamestown in 1619.
We'll talk more about
that in the next video.